uh chatted with this man during the uh
nfl draft as part of the draft-a-thon
helping raise money
um and uh a big fan of his work and
pleased to have right here on the rich
eisen show in advance of
the latest must-see of his uh acting
career the comey rule a two-night event
premieres on consecutive nights first
night is coming up this sunday and then
monday
uh at nine eastern time on showtime the
man who plays
jim comey the former fbi director jeff
daniels here on the rich eisen show how
are you jeff
i'm doing fine rich i'm pleased to have
you on this program
uh and uh you know last week we spoke
you were you were feeling good about uh
potentially your lying season
um i don't know you want to talk about
your work you want to talk about the
alliance
jeff what do you want to do first well
let's get to the lions first
uh they break your heart
they don't just lose they lose and they
break your heart
doing so uh it's just you can't be ahead
17 to 3 or whatever it was or 23 to 6 or
something you just know
if you lean towards we're going to win
you're going to get your heart broken
and and we're it's just
you think we're cursed we i don't know
but it's
it's it's getting difficult it's getting
real difficult well i mean obviously
week one was particularly
um troubling in the fact that it looked
like you had everything all
all wrapped up um so uh
i guess when you say it it breaks your
heart it you're still
you're still with them right i mean
you're not you're not going anywhere
right jeff well they're on in the
background
let me put it that way okay
it's hard to uh sit there you know
leaning forward
into the television set when you're you
know you're gonna get your heart broken
so sometimes you leave them on in the
event that something
crazy happens like we're ahead by two
touchdowns with 30 seconds to go but
still
hang on um but then
but but generally to end these first two
games it's been the same
thing it's just like and in the second
half we're gonna break your heart
it's like okay okay okay okay
so who is your guy growing up who is the
the the guy who got you
falling in love i guess with the lions
or were rooting for
just watching football in general who
would that be just i don't i don't know
why
but it was dale cogdill he was a wide
receiver for the lions ms8 late
60s okay he was on the team with alex
karis roger brown wayne walker
milt plum okay
nick petrosante i remember uh
night train lane of course right yeah
those guys when they were playing in
tigers stadium yeah so when you're
i went down for one of the thanksgiving
games i sat in the end zone i remember
it's one of my earliest memories we were
sitting in the end zone
at tiger stadium uh you know you
remember it like a couple of snapshots
so you're so you you and your family
would go to thanksgiving games
actual lions games before once i
remember once i wouldn't say it was a
regular saying
okay so that's i i haven't i've never
heard of him
before jeff i got to be honest with you
i i thought i might get somebody a
little bit more
you know famous for his work with the
lions or the national football league
what what who is this person again yeah
i i i don't know why
i think his number was 89 i think i
didn't remember the number but
that was just when i was eight years old
and i had a football in the yard i was
gail cocktail
gail cogdale is that right i think so
god i hope it's that google it but i i
think
it is that was that's yeah he made three
pro bowls in
60 62 and 63.
thank you thank you i'm not an idiot
we backed your play jeff 34 career
touchdowns okay there you go
that's yeah that's okay and that's the
guy who got jeff daniels loving
loving the lions and now to this day
you're living and dying with your
with your uh with your detroit lions are
you a detroit sports fan across the
board or is it just uh the lions
for you yeah across the board i i the
detroit tigers are
probably number one with the lions close
second the red wings were
and still are you know i love i love
that team the pistons i just i was never
a basketball guy so
less so with that okay did you ever play
football yourself jeff
do you ever get that out high school i
was a high school you know
small town high school you know stud and
as soon as you go against up
kids with from either bigger high
schools or college it's you realize that
you need to major in theater okay now
this is a very important
question for me uh personally uh are you
michigan or michigan state
which one do you root for uh
or none semi root both i went to central
michigan oregon
went to central michigan one of the
all-time great advances
yes he did um yeah that was no i really
my kids
went to state on saturday nights i'd go
to ann arbor as a kid
okay other than that there's really no
affiliation there's no [ __ ] because i'm
a wolverine class of 1990 jeff
so and it's funny i'm a new yorker i'm a
new yorker and so going to
michigan i'd never been in the midwest
in my entire life quite honestly
and so uh when i would use the word
sneakers
or talk about having a soda or
just the simple thing of uh crossing the
street and cars stopping for me because
i'm
walking in the street was just really
weird for me the whole experience
was just seeing life as a i guess
a different person than i did growing up
on the east coast
you know yeah it's uh it's a little
different
out here yeah uh yeah yeah and when we
see people like you from the east coast
who tell us they're from the east coast
yes
uh yeah we tend to stare at you a little
bit longer
you know you finish your sentence and we
go yeah
yeah that sounded almost intelligent
yeah i love
you coming from a mile away i know and
and and but then i would stare back
when they're like no it's not soda it's
pop it's not sneakers it's tennis shoes
it's not sprinkles it's jimmy's and then
uh then they would ask me do i want to
uke
and i thought that meant do i want to
actually vomit i had no idea they were
meaning a card game called
euchre like that was new for me too you
know
yes yeah there's so much to learn yeah
yeah i i wish i'd known you back then
you could have helped me uh you know
get uh more acclimated i've got jeff
daniels here
on the rich eisen show tell me about the
comey rules sir what did you learn about
jim comey did you learn anything uh that
you might not have already known or you
brought into
uh working on this uh remarkable
two-night event jeff well i think the
audience is going to learn what i
learned which is
what jim was thinking um when and
particularly in october 2016 when the
fbi reopened the investigation into
hillary's emails
you're going to understand why he did it
he may not agree with it still but
his decision but he was he was between a
rock and a hard place
and the movie shows him in that moment
and he has to decide between one or the
other
constantly he was was put in positions
like that
you know where it was just a tough tough
call and none of it had to do with being
political and that was the other thing i
learned
here is a political guy you know he
was a republican but now he's the fbi
director doesn't vote
because he can't and he's not left and
he's not right so when he makes a
decision
his north star is the rule of law uh the
institution that is the department of
justice
truth facts and maintaining the
integrity of the fbi those are the
things that
nothing those are the things he he looks
at and
uh those are those things are all bigger
than he is
and that became his north star
and and that that was i didn't know all
that and
and he doesn't think politically he
can't he's not allowed to when he makes
these decisions even though everyone who
is political
is screaming at him for being political
he was an apolitical public servant and
he led the way
for people like fiona hill
marie ivanovic william taylor colonel
benmen and
others jim was like that first a
political public servant that was thrown
in front of this
political nightmare that we're living
this this divisive
polarized country that we are jim was
thrown right in the middle
of that and he's going i'm making the
decision from an apolitical point of
view and people started screaming
did you meet with him prior to or during
the shooting of this
i met him during i i i offered to meet
him before
i was doing uh to kill a mockingbird
atticus finch on broadway and i was in
the end of a year-long run
right and i emailed him once we got it i
emailed said
you know if you're in new york you know
where to find me and
because we were going to start shooting
right after mockingbird
um and and jim emailed back he was very
nice but he had no plans to come up to
new york
i had had i read the book the audiobook
would you have read it
youtube you've got every all the film
you the video you'd want on him
even on the colbert show you could see
comey's sense of humor
as as as an actor playing any character
that's a lot of material going in so i
didn't
you know i offered to meet him and and
he didn't
you know we didn't and so i didn't want
to impose
i didn't want to be one of these actors
who went down and ate dinner at his
house so i could watch him eat dinner
i i just didn't want to do that right
did you see that
then we were two months into shooting
yes and and then he showed up on the set
and that was he he watched the first two
takes of the loyalty dinner
between me and brendan gleason who plays
trump
and after two takes billy ray the writer
director said i want you to meet
somebody and oh god there he is
and he realized that he huh you didn't
know he was there watching
i was i knew he was coming that day
right right but
the loyalty dinner was you know all
hands on deck
all focus on that so it was like yeah
whatever i'll
feed him whatever i got to do this um
but he came around the corner he'd been
watching
and he had a he he kind of looked
he said you brought the emotion back you
brought the struggle you brought
everything i was thinking like what the
hell am i supposed to
say and do at this moment he goes like i
gotta be honest i feel a little nauseous
and usually when you tell an actor that
their performance makes them nauseous
it's not a good thing right but i took
it as a conflict
yes because you brought back all all
those moments right there what do you
think trump's going to think of this
if he's out there watching on sunday and
monday oh he's going to hate it he's
going to hate it
if he even pays attention to it my hope
is that he'll be too busy
not preparing for the first debate to
have time to watch
thank god that's your hope on all that
jeff daniels here on the rich eisen show
and again
um the uh comey rule is going to be
available
starting sunday night and then monday uh
two nights
um nine eastern on show time um
one one of the things i want to just hit
with you out of your whole
career um is terms of endearment jeff
because that's one of the first for you
uh
being on the set jack and shirley mclean
for crying out loud
what was that like for you back in 1983
to be involved in
and play a character spoiler alert it
was a bit of a heel what was that like
for you
jeff uh it was uh
what's the phrase keep your eyes open
your mouth shut your ears open your mind
whatever it was shut
up and i would go to the set on days
that jack would work
when i wasn't supposed to work just to
watch him really and i learned a lot
you know you think jack nicholson comes
in and is perfect right away he's not
he's trying to figure it out and as a
young actor i got to see this
this pro uh work the first take in the
second take and the third take
and then he kind of becomes and he says
i got it and then they roll
and just take four five six seven those
are the ones you use
it just was an education in film acting
i remember jim brooks the director
said to jack after a couple of tastes
jack we got that i want to
i want to try something a little crazy i
want to go out on the limb with
something and jack
said i love going out on a limb i get in
trouble out there
and i as a young actor you're going
that's it that's the thing
risk failure risk it and it was a great
lesson i learned a lot working with jack
in particular and
everybody i mean it was your you're a 28
year old actor
with shirley debra and jack nicholson i
mean
what's wrong with this picture right and
there was nothing wrong with that
picture i mean the picture was it's it's
perfect it stands to
test the time and we've had so many um
um actors from a few good men in here
um kevin bacon and noah wiley and kevin
pollock we've had rob reiner and i asked
him about that famous scene
involving jack nicholson all the time
and they said that nicholson
would do his lines for everyone else
when it was their turn to be on camera
for that scene
and he did it the same exact way every
damn time
and then they just then he did it the
same way that's what pros do
that that's uh jack the fact that a jack
would do there are many who don't
you know there are many who once the
camera's not on them the script
supervisor reads
the lines because he's either going home
right or that actor is you know and that
that happens that's what star that's
what you learn in star school
but jack no i mean when you see a jack
do that or romero street do that
and it's full out off camera that's
that's what it's all about
and that was i learned that early too
and that's that's uh
it's a great lesson it's not just about
you it's about that other person in the
scene with you make them great too
give it to them jeff daniels here on the
rich eisen show again the comey rule
uh i can't wait to for everyone to see
it uh it's amazing you're amazing in it
um
and i appreciate the call and let me
know if you want to run through some
lines of a loyalty test for the lions if
that's what you want to have like a
loyalty dinner for your detroit lions if
you need to ever do that
jeff it may come to that yes well we've
got something i don't know if you're
you're not watching but we are placing
on the screen here to make sure
everyone understands that you know what
you're talking about that's a gail
cogdill football trading card that we're
putting up on the
screen right there number 89 in your
program number one in your heart jeff
right up there on our screen that's
right my heart's a flutter
thanks for the call jeff really
appreciate it and uh congrats in advance
on
on on the comey rule thanks rich
right back at you that's jeff daniels at
jeff underscore daniels right here
on the program hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here